regardless of what is going to happen in
the film in the end regardless of what
kind of post effects are gonna be
applied to the film what kind of visual
effects really the only thing I'm
thinking about is is whether it's a
movie that I want to see or not so my
greatest care and concern is is it's
gonna be a good film previous to me is
exactly like storyboards they're they're
simple blueprints for what you're gonna
do now how are you gonna film a movie
well when Chris Knoll and I do when he
does storyboards and we go over the
storyboards together we get a clearer
idea of what's in our head well I think
a lot of that low-tech previz if you
will happens right up here you know what
I'm reading the script the first pass it
really is about story but the second
pass it really is creating imagery in up
here and then really that imagery
changes and you know is molded by what
the director and the production designer
are doing and what where they're headed
so the visuals start building even
though you're not going to put it in the
camera and even know some of it might be
a visual effect the visuals really start
building through drawings of the sets
that are to be built or in the case of
the film's that we do with Chris the
locations the actual locations the great
use of previous is-is-is for mechanical
things to see how a mechanical rig needs
to be if the shot that's in the previs
seems to work for the director and it's
something and it seems like that's the
way he's gonna want it to appear on the
screen then it gives the productions on
an exact idea of what the frame lines is
going to be it gives the the effects
people a look and the visual effects
people an idea of what they have to
recreate later on inception had an awful
lot of visual effects in it in the end
but I think that if you asked Chris
Nolan he would have the same responses
that it really didn't feel to us like
we're making visual effects film we had
very little green screen work in the end
we still shot most of the film on
location and really it was the visual
effects department that was sort of
following us we didn't cater to them we
shot handheld they had to
- you know rotoscope to get the visual
effects
I think that's really Nolan's philosophy
is to have the visual effects trying to
play catch up with us and trying to work
off of our photography that's shot in
the real world the part where Alan page
opens up the mirrors a hundred percent
mechanical effect except that I was
removed from the shot yeah you know I
have the camera on my shoulder filming
the shot and standing right there in the
mirror and that's the only effect and in
that bit was I was erased from the shot
and and so that's that is an example of
sort of a Chris Nolan visual effect what
a clever director and in a smart visual
effects supervisor will do is they'll
consult with the director of photography
in their post work to make sure that the
work that they do gels with what the
cinematographer has been doing
throughout the film we do have our
little secrets we do have our little
paths that really nobody including the
director knows how we get there and so
the visual effects people need to be let
in on those secrets to be able to
recreate that and what they do no matter
what they're gonna have to match what
we've done so it's important for them to
pay close attention to what we're doing
so the process that I've had on the
Nolan pictures is when they're in the
process of visual effects months and
months and months after principal
photography the film the visual effects
supervisor generally sends me tips or
JPEGs of what they have going on the
visual effects I'll often take those
stills bring them into Photoshop do some
color work and some contrast work on
them to get them where I think it's
going to match the color timing and I'm
planning on doing on the film and and
then send it back to them and then they
work off of that so we go back and forth
with that process a little bit in post
my advice for cinematographers and for
young filmmakers is not to get hung up
in the technology and not to worry about
the changes in the technology think
about the craft of storytelling think of
the the craft and the art of
cinematography of
great composition of beautiful lighting
of appropriate camera movement that's
what filmmaking is about it's not about
bit you know bit depth and it's not
about megapixels and it's not even about
you know strips of film it is really
about the storytelling and putting it on
the screen in an appropriate way so
that's what they need to continue
focusing on the the next generation of
filmmakers what we're looking for are
people to give us interesting stories
not people who can drive machines
you